BACK TO YOU.
>> Charles: THANKS, BILL.
SO LET'S GET THE READ ON THIS
NOW FROM FORMER ACTING HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY HERITAGE
FOUNDATION, CHAD WOLF.
WE CONTINUE TO HEAR THE NUMBERS
AND STORIES OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEY CONTINUE TO AMAZE,
CONTINUING TO MIND BOGGLE.
I'M ALMOST SHOCKED THAT HALF DID
SHOW UP TO BE FRANK WITH YOU.
THIS NTR PROGRAM, IT'S BEEN
DISCONTINUED BUT WHO THOUGHT
THIS WOULD WORK IN THE FIRST
PLACE?
>> WELL, IT'S THE HONOR SYSTEM,
RIGHT?
THEY'RE ASKING MIGRANTS TO SHOW
UP AT A LOCAL ICE OFFICE.
THERE'S NO WAY TO TRACK THAT.
THERE'S NO WAY TO KNOW WHERE
THEY ARE.
THE REASON WHY THEY DID IT, IF
YOU RECALL, IN MARCH, APRIL, MAY
AND JUNE IS BECAUSE THEY WERE
OVERWHELMED AT THE BORDER.
THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN AND ALL
OF THEIR POLICIES SINCE THEY
TOOK OVER, THEY'VE BEEN
ENCOURAGING MIGRANTS TO COME TO
THE BORDER, CLAIM ASYLUM AND
MOWING THAT THE MAJORITY ARE
FALSE CLAIMS.
IT'S NO SURPRISED THAT THEY GOT
OVERWHELMED.
THEY COULDN'T DO THE PROPER
PAPERWORK TO ISSUE NOTICE OF
APPEARS.
INSTEAD, NOTICES TO REPORT.
IT'S THE HONOR SYSTEM.
SO TO HAVE 50,000 JUST THROUGH
AUGUST, WE NEED TO KEEP IN MIND
THE HAITIANS IN DEL RIO WAS IN
SEPTEMBER.
I CAN GUARANTEE YOU, THE
MAJORITY OF THOSE WERE ISSUED
NOTICE TO REPORTS AS WELL.
SO THAT NUMBER, 47, 48,000 IS
PROBABLY MUCH HIGHER AS YOU GO
ALL THE WAY THROUGH THE END OF
2021.
>> Charles: WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE MESSAGING DURING THE
ELECTION, WHICH WAS HEY, YOU
KNOW, COME ON UP, RED CARPET,
GREEN LIGHT, COME ON UP.
WE HAVE VACANCIES.
IN RECENT WEEKS, WE'VE GOT NEW
YORK CITY ON THE VERGE OF
ALLOWING HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF UNDOCUMENTED MIGRANTS VOTE
AND NOW THE GOVERNOR IN
CALIFORNIA PROMISING ECONOMIC
BENEFITS AS WELL.
HOW DO YOU STEM -- HOW DO YOU
CONTROL YOUR BORDER, IN ANY
COUNTRY, ANY NATION IN THE WORLD
WHEN ONCE YOU GET THROUGH, YOU
KNOW THAT YOU -- THE HONOR
SYSTEM YOU'LL NEVER HAVE TO
REPORT BACK?
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO VOTE AND
YOU'LL ALSO HAVE ECONOMIC GAINS?
REALLY, IT'S -- I'M ASKING
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A LOT
OF CITIZENS IN THIS COUNTRY --
WE'RE THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD, THE KINDEST HEARTS IN
THE WORLD.
WIFE LOST BLOOD, TRES SURES,
SPENT TRILLIONS TO HELP
EVERYBODY AROUND THE PLANET.
SHOULD WE NOT BE SMARTER WITH
ORGANIZING THE WAY WE LET FOLKS
IN?
THIS SEEMS LIKE IT'S A FREE FOR
ALL.
>> IT IS CREATING A FREE FOR
THAT'S WHY HAVE SEEN THE WORST
BORDER CRISIS EVER IN OUR
LIFETIMES.
THE UNITED STATES IS ONE OF THE
MOST GENEROUS AND WELCOMING
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD.
THERE'S A LEGAL WAY, AND ORDERLY
WAY AND PROCESS TO GET IN TO THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
WHEN YOU DISCARD THAT AND YOU'RE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND YOU
PUT FORTH POLICIES AND MESSAGES
THAT ENCOURAGES ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR
TO COME ACROSS, YOU END UP WITH
WHAT YOU HAVE TODAY, WHICH IS A
COLOSSAL FAILURE.
THAT'S WHAT IS LEADING -- A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE SCRATCHING THEIR
HEADS SAYING WHAT IS GOING ON?
IT'S NOT ONLY THE MIGRANTS BUT